you gave a d minus the economist so are
they two like the politicians to wash
in terms of there's good ideas and bad
ideas and and that tiny delta between
good and
bad is how you squeak past the f plus
onto the d minus territory
i think most economic ideas are bad
ideas like most
you know like um
take us back to mit and you want to
solve
a fluid dynamics problem like like
design the shape of the hull of that
ship
or you want to design an airfoil a wing
or if you want to design
an engine or a
a nozzle and a rocket ship
you wouldn't do it with simple
arithmetic
you wouldn't do it with a scalar there's
not a single number right it's vector
it's vector math you know computational
fluid dynamics is n-dimensional
higher level math you know complicated
stuff
so when when an economist says the
inflation rate is two percent that's a
scalar and when an economist says
it's not a problem to print more money
because the velocity of the money is
very low the monetary velocity is low
that's another scalar
okay so
the truth of the matter is
inflation is not a scalar inflation is
an in-dimensional vector
money velocity is not a scalar
develo saying what's the velocity of
money
oh oh it's slow or it's fast
it ignores the question of what medium
is the money moving through
and the same way that you know
what's the speed of sound
okay well what is sound right
sound you know sound is uh is a
compression wave it's energy
moving through a medium but the speed is
different
so for example the speed of sound
through air is different than the speed
of sound through water
and and a sound moves faster through
water it moves faster through a solid
and it moves faster to a stiffer solid
so there isn't one
what is the fundamental problem with the
way economists reduce the world down to
a model is it too simple
or is it just even the first principles
of constructing the model is wrong
i think that the fundamental problem is
if you see the world as a scalar you
simply pick
the one number which is
which supports whatever you want to do
and you ignore
the universe of other
consequences from your behavior
in general i don't know if you've heard
of um
like eric watson has been talking about
this with gage theory so different
different kinds of approaches
from the physics world from the
mathematical world to
extend past this
scalar view of economics so gage theory
is one way that comes from physics
do you find that
a way of exploring economics interesting
so outside of cryptocurrency outside of
the actual technologies and so on just
uh analysis of how economics works do
you find that interesting
yeah i i think that if we're going to
want to really make any scientific
progress in economics we have to apply
much
much more computationally intensive and
richer forms of mathematics
so simulation perhaps or
yeah you know when i was at mit i
studied system dynamics
you know they taught it at the sloan
school it was developed by jay forrester
who
who um
was an extraordinary computer scientist
and um
when we created models of
economic behavior they were all
multi-dimensional non-linear models so
if you want to describe how
anything works in the real world you
have to start with the concept of
feedback
if i double the price of something
demand will fall and attempts to
to create supply will increase and there
will be a delay
before the capacity increases
there'll be an instant demand
change and there'll be rippling effects
throughout every other segment of the
economy downstream and upstream of such
thing
so it's kind of common sense
but most economics most classical
economics it's always
you know taught with linear models
you know fairly simplistic linear models
and oftentimes even i'm really shocked
today
that the entire uh mainstream dialogue
of economics has been captured by scalar
arithmetic
for example
if if you read uh
you know read any article in new york
times or the wall street journal right
they just refer to it there's an
inflation number or the the cpi or
the inflation rate is x
and if you look at all the historic
studies
of the impact of inflation
generally they're all based upon
the idea that inflation equals cpi and
then they try to extrapolate from that
and you just get nowhere with it
so
at the very least we should be
considering inflation and other
economics concept as a non-linear
dynamical system so non-linearity and
also just embracing the full complexity
of just how the variables interact maybe
through simulation maybe some
have some interesting models around that
wouldn't it be refreshing if somebody
for once published a table of the change
in price of every product every service
and every asset and every place over
time
you